Republicans are now desperately
rethinking if and how they should be
talking about abortion during their
campaigns because of the disastrous flop
of the 2022 midterms remember that in
2022
historically speaking Republicans should
have done unbelievably well they should
have probably taken control of the
Senate which they did not they actually
lost ground in the Senate going from 50
to 49 seats they should have taken
control of the house with a much greater
margin but they did not and now
Republicans are in the situation of
having to rethink their strategy there's
an interesting Hill article by Julia
Manchester which says Republicans are
recalibrating their messaging on
abortion after Democrats successfully
used the issue to Galvanize their base
and win over swing voters in 2022 while
the GOP largely focused on the
three-pronged message of combating
rising inflation crime and the flow of
migrants over the Border exit polls
showed abortion was a top priority for
voters at The Ballot Box
Republican committee chair Ronald
McDaniel said quote it was probably a
bigger Factor than a lot of people
thought
we've got to get conversant on that we
can't just do an ostrich method and
pretend that it doesn't exist when
Democrats are spending 30 million
dollars on that message according to
exit polling 27 of Voters said abortion
was the most important issue coming in
only behind inflation at 31 so there's a
few things to understand here in general
abortion is a deeply polarizing issue
and so there's always a risk when you
campaign on either side of a really
polarizing issue that you're gonna
alienate a large swath of the electorate
that's just a general thing with
polarizing issues the issue in
particular with abortion for Republicans
is that not only is it polarizing but
the country continues to be more and
more and more in favor of abortion being
legal in most cases and in fact we've
we've seen a steady increase in the Roe
v Wade era which ended a few months ago
in Americans generally speaking saying
yeah in most cases this should be legal
and so when you take that away a as the
Supreme Court did as a right
and then Republicans can campaign on how
great that is it's not necessarily going
to be useful to you
secondly abortion is a distraction in a
sense to more pressing issues that
Americans feel that they are facing in
the sense that Republicans could be
focusing on the economy Healthcare
education for and foreign policy without
the drag of their position on abortion
being there and what I mean by that is
the following
Republicans tried to make their
campaigns to a degree about inflation
and the border and Biden's bad and
whatever and we can adjudicate whether
that's a good or bad idea on its own but
they were dragged down by the knowledge
and the timing of the Roe v Wade diverse
reversal by the Supreme Court and so
many Republicans saying that that was a
really great thing and so that was also
a problem for republicans and the the
maybe last part of this is of course I'm
pro-choice you all know that
but the American people are mostly
pro-choice and so the Republican
position on abortion with some
Republicans saying there should be some
exceptions but putting that aside it's a
flawed and misguided ideology and as I
mentioned before
the position of Republicans is based on
the assumption that abortion is morally
wrong it should be banned it should be
illegal maybe it's murder in many cases
regardless of the situation or the
circumstances it ignores the reality
that most Americans don't see it that
way and of course it ignores the reality
that sometimes abortion is necessary
it's an important option for women to
have and it should not be something in
which the government is involved so on
so many levels this is a misguided
strategy so what's going to happen next
we saw it backfire at The Ballot Box in
part there's lots of things that we can
blame for what happened in November but
to a degree the position on abortion of
the Republican party was a factor so do
they stop talking about abortion that's
a problem because Republicans still
raise a disproportionate amount of money
from religious voters by saying we are
against abortion what do they do if they
don't talk about it there's a risk
talking about it the way they have
talked about it is also a risk so in
total the Republican party's position on
abortion is flawed
medically
it's flawed morally and ethically but
it's also flawed strategically if they
want to win elections and be successful
they're going to need to do a rethink I
don't know what that rethink should be I
don't care I don't want them to win so
it's not for me to start giving them
advice but we'll have to track and see
whether in some of the 2023 elections
abortion takes on a sort of different
tone from the Republican party and
certainly going into 2024. let me know
if you do have thoughts how should the
Republican Party straddle being against
abortion but the reality that
increasingly the country is in favor of
it